what would you like to see change
quality as in general that's what should
happen and across all boards walkabout -
glamour with me Josh Smith and today we
are joined by a genuine sporting
superstar and she's the queen of sugar
paper it's Maria Sharapova thank you for
having me what in a chair Wow winning we
we are twinning cuz twinning is always
winning Marie just to get straight into
it you've had the most epic race and
like your story is so inspiring
what has determination taught you well
the sport itself since starting from a
very young age there's so much of it was
repetition and focus and grind because
it was all about numbers like the more
that you did the better you became the
more confident you became at a shot or
stroke that mentality I think grew over
time and it's taking me to other parts
of my career there's so many things in a
sporting career that you learn along the
way you've all such a sacrifice and all
for you life as well being away from my
family for a long period of time is
really tough I moved to the United
States from Russia when I was just at
six years old and I didn't see my mom
for the first two years so sacrifices
like those which there are no guarantees
and tennis particularly there's no
guarantees in life you do everything you
can to become a champion and you try to
get the best resources if you commit
yourself mentally financially from
everyone around you for this one goal
and you never know if it's gonna work
out cuz what do you not about yourself
free.they sacrifices and those moments
of sacrifice well I've learned that the
way that I handle a situation that comes
at me for example if it's losing a
particular match that was really tough
and I was up and ahead and I ended up on
the losing end of things the way that I
come off the court the way that I think
about it mentally in the way that I
process it and take it not as failure
but something that didn't work out if I
can think like that in my sporting world
I'll be able to take those few little
things and bring it up to my life so
much of life I believe is about
perspective it basically teaches a great
determination let's get real I don't
know I'm still I think everyone is
always a work in progress and that's
some things that I'm good at and
some things that I'm fragile at and then
something's any temper that what would
you say you'll mace my child I'm quite
impatient so I'm always itching to see
what will come out of the work that I
put in say if you have someone here
who's like I'm feeling like I'm lacking
just have a nation what would you say to
them Oh keep keep doing it sometimes it
only takes a few people to tell you that
they believe in you for all the others
that maybe don't if it's my family if
it's my friend it's the people that know
you and that matter to you their
information is much more valuable
because of the years that they've spent
with you because they know you inside
out if you remember a time when they
particularly picked you up
always I'm an only child I'm like a
golden child in a sense where so much of
their life is focused around me
especially when I was younger because my
father was my coach you know my mother
did everything in order to make me
comfortable and you know she made me
carry juice in the morning because I was
short and she thought if I drink carrot
juice like I would grow and I'd be
taller
I support because that's I needed that
because well there's such an interesting
debate around body image at the moment
and you've literally grown up in the
public eye you have such a healthy body
image it seems what was your journey
been like I was a lot taller and I was
very skinny when I was young and so I
was wobbly and I didn't always feel
stable particularly in tennis so I was
definitely an an odd one out I was doing
well and I was training so much and I
was playing tournaments and I was
beating a lot of girls that were older
and I and I don't think that was very
popular so I felt like I was on a
mission to become a professional athlete
and that mission was waking up in the
morning early and training and going to
sleep early and you know I didn't have
access to a lot of things and not too
many sleepovers and other activities or
going to the mall I didn't know any
other way that kept me a focus on my job
because I think we all have down moments
when we focus on our body team and we're
like oh my god
but you make sure you have to go out
there and compete in short dresses in
these outfits of course body like when
you're out there and you're sweating and
you're trying to beat your opponent
honestly you don't think about your body
anymore
just trying to do everything you can to
win which is kind of like a positive
thing that maybe we should all do in
their lives is actually take the
pressure off our own body and actually
just focus in my mind more because
that's basically what you're doing right
yeah some of your press conferences is
watching them and the amount of sexist
questions you can ask on a daily basis
is actually unbelievable how do you deal
with sexist questions when you can ask
them I've been prepared ever since I was
young what's interesting about tennis is
we have to go to a press conference win
or lose after every single match I don't
think about it that much because my
focus is so much of what the real job is
there is that questions can get tricky
and questions might not fall in line
with what you thought they would be
asking you and that's okay I think
that's kind of how life is like you get
things thrown at you and you have to do
it and you have to accept and then you
go on and you go on with your life
how do you actually focus I think focus
is such like it's such a difficult thing
today well I have one priority and I
don't we always know what that one thing
is for me that's always been my sport
the feeling of just being an athlete
like when I wouldn't used to travel and
you always have to fill out immigration
forms and it said what is your
occupation yeah my favorite thing was to
write athlete yeah that's when I wake up
and I put on my sports gear I love that
feeling of knowing that I can be better
at my craft I'll get on the court and
I'll train and my mind is a hundred
percent there what I'm off it there's
very little that I can do so I'm like
challenging my mind I like putting on
the businesswoman hat and yeah I'm like
where can I take myself because another
thing that's very charged around women
is for it's always the equal pay debate
and you've always been such an amazing
kind of like almost like a feminist icon
in your own right because you've been
the highest paid female athlete in the
world like you've been so prominent how
as an athlete competing and as a word
she finds that debate now I still feel
like it's a debate I don't feel that
female athletes are fighting for that
equality which is the right thing to do
but is it right to still be doing it in
2019 no but again it's another thing
that we we have to fight for and we do
because it's part of our profession it's
part of our life and we always fight for
what we believe in what would you like
to see change equality as in general
that's what should happen and across all
boards no matter what sport no matter
what profession did you say has been the
best piece of advice you've been given
on your career journey you know I think
you always have to keep your feet on the
ground and I mean my mother is just an
incredible example of that because she's
to always say to me when I had a tough
patch you say life is like a zebra you
have the white line and then you have a
bottom line and then and then when you
think of you like wait but when things
are gonna go well it's not gonna so I'm
gonna keep going like that's the
trajectory of life like you're always
gonna have ups and downs and I know you
so many people have heard it's not about
how you do well but where do you find
like the book man's search for meaning
when everything is taken away from your
life and when you're stripped down from
all the luxuries as little as big as
they are and you have nothing else like
what do you left for that I think that's
a really inspiring
question in that situation what you look
for to be healthy to be happy to be
around people that I love and that I
admire and I I just like improving my
own self you have to get out there you
have to face opposition you have to face
your fears you have to face things that
are not necessarily comfortable how do
you deal with negativity when you come
across because you were just touching on
social media and that's a place where
there is a lot of negativity and a lot
of positivity how do you deal with it as
long as it's just a feeling like it's
normal to react it's normal to be
sensitive to criticism and I don't think
you should ever you know stand up and
say no that doesn't bother me at all
there are certain things that will
bother you how impactful are those words
how impactful are those people do they
really matter to you is that someone
whose opinion you really care about and
if it's not okay you're sensitive you
feel you know feel a little crap
how'd you get what I do and what I put
out and what I give
I think is what matters okay I think
opinions are healthy because that's what
makes the world go around I think if
everyone always thought great things
about what you said and what you wore
that would be fun no I accept it for
what it is it shouldn't influence or
impact your life to such a huge level
when you think butts that 70 year old
girl seventeen year old girl he like
fell to my knees
won Wimbledon yeah what's difference
between that girl and the Maria that's
before us today well I think you live so
much of life you know winning Wimbledon
at 17 s so it's magical and it it
becomes even more magical than more
years that go by because when you're in
that moment at such a young age you
don't doesn't really hit you get some
really cool paycheck and very grumpy and
then very instant it's in the moment but
it's really the reflection that is is
really really nice what would you say to
someone he was gonna come ta I'm here
before you right now I want to get a
little bit more empowered like Maria
Sharapova be yourself in a world where
we're influenced by so many people and
buy so many things we sometimes lose
track of what we care about what we want
to do sometimes it's good to ask
yourself is that what I really want to
do is that what I want to say is that
how I want to go about my life are these
the choices that are important to me
ultimately you have to be happy and your
own skin Thanks look into the mirror
and asking yourself the question am i
happy with the choices that are making
but when you look back at your
incredible career and you've got so much
left of your career to go what would you
say is the low you've learned the most
from and the high you've learned the
most from I still think that maybe those
are ahead of me yeah yeah I never think
that there's something that was so
impactful in a way that I always
consistently look back at that because
the future is always ahead of us right
yes yeah life is much better from the
front in front of the steering wheel
than the rear view mirror also do you
now have sugar python which is another
insanely male-dominated fingers business
how has it been for you being a female
businesswoman
I love being a female businesswoman in
the candy world yes it is I mean
complete different spectrums what's been
interesting has been coming into
something in which I didn't have a lot
of knowledge from that perspective that
was difficult but it actually I forced
the questions that maybe other people in
the room men or women didn't actually
think about it because they were in
there every single day so that I enjoy
you know and I've certainly I've learned
about the business speaking of growing
we just launched in England which is
very exciting
Tintin dead hey you are spraying these
candies everywhere yes the new woody
won't curb the tears hell my favorite
movie for more epic videos like this
with Paquette people like Maria
Sharapova make sure you subscribe to
glamour UK channels now to be done here
yes great join maria and go on with it
guys
[Music]
you
[Music]